[SPEAKER_00]: Knock on the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you want, Jude?
[SPEAKER_00]: What are you saying?
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a knock on the door.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm gonna go invisible.
[SPEAKER_01]: You are important to me.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I use my ring and I go invisible.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: He washed towards the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm moved to kind of parallel.
[SPEAKER_01]: I am completely ready to either fireball or stab somebody in the gut with a knife.
[SPEAKER_01]: He moves to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to move right next to him so that I have the first glimpse on what's coming through the door.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or if that's a window, I'll move to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the door.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's support.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to be here?
[SPEAKER_01]: What?
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to be here because I want to intercept.
[SPEAKER_00]: Come there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can't say it at all.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think we're good, but they are eating some guac.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you walk up... No, they're good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are you?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hey, Elise.
[SPEAKER_00]: Stop.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're playing the game.
[SPEAKER_00]: I need a transcript that doesn't have you in it all the fuckin' time.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just asking you if you would like to explode, and you said no.
[SPEAKER_00]: I am doing duty signs.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, I'm right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to be able to intercept with a spell anybody that comes in to attack him.
[SPEAKER_00]: He opens the board.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just a little... Yeah, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I help you?
[SPEAKER_00]: A dagger comes through the fucking door and stabs him in the eye.
[SPEAKER_00]: He falls backwards.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Fuck it, I like put my palm up through the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait, hang on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to put your palm in the door?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean like, the dagger's already through.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I thrust him back.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, he falls on the ground right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: A niche.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll a niche.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Damn it, what do I have for a niche?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have dice?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I got my own dice.
[SPEAKER_01]: I got my own dice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dexterity's 18, so I have a plus four to a niche.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it going first?
[SPEAKER_00]: I didn't see.
[SPEAKER_01]: You do not go first.
[SPEAKER_00]: Someone looks through the door and there is a
[SPEAKER_00]: That shots through it.
[SPEAKER_01]: In the head.
[SPEAKER_01]: A crossbow bolt?
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, wait.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he took a dagger and a crossbow bolt?
[SPEAKER_01]: And a crossbow bolt.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I just inter...
[SPEAKER_01]: I did say a second.
[SPEAKER_01]: I threw my hand up.
[SPEAKER_01]: If I can intercept it with my hand, I will totally take the bolt.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's your initiative?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, my initiative's not.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, they beat me on it.
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: They beat you on that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just saying I'll take the shot.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you have a spell that can do reaction.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I do the shield?
[SPEAKER_00]: Shield.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you have shield?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, I do have shield.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's on yourself, though.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not something we can do on somebody else.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I did say I stuck my hand in the center.
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, alright, alright, but I'm trying, I'm trying.
[SPEAKER_00]: Six plus four, the bolt shoots down next to the guy's head.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he goes down because he's got a dagger in his eye and a bolt just barely misses.
[SPEAKER_01]: It misses.
[SPEAKER_01]: Barely misses.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know if it's his eye, it's his eye, but it's his face.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: You miss the initiative.
[SPEAKER_00]: Someone pounds the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: Here's the roll for that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like tries to break it down?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Your turn.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I'm going to look at my character.
[SPEAKER_01]: Damn it.
[SPEAKER_01]: How does casting an area effect work?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like if I wanted to cast fireball and I went ahead and moved right in front of the slit, can I cast fireball right on the outside of the door because I can see through the slit?
[SPEAKER_00]: And by the way, you are an evoker, so you have what's called.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, so I can say it can wrap around me and him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, it can wrap around
[SPEAKER_00]: Your intelligence bonus plus one, so your int is what?
[SPEAKER_00]: Four laws.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: Four plus one is five.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can exclude five people.
[SPEAKER_00]: So if you want to cast a fireball through the door and burn people right out in front of the door, period.
[SPEAKER_01]: As far as my fireball will take, from the door forward.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I would literally fireball.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so do you want to move somewhere?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll just move like, I mean it's got to be like 10 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to be right in front of the door?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to go here?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well do I, but that's what I was asking is that do I need to see through?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because if I need to see through... You do, but it's like if you're right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can see a lot if you want to do right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I'm going to see a lot because I'm like desperate to make this work.
[SPEAKER_00]: But if you do that, there's somebody out there with reaction that can attack you.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you're saying that I can do it from back here and they can't attack me and I would know that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then I'll do it.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'll back up.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'll move from here to here.
[SPEAKER_00]: So Jude walks 10 feet from the doorway, the portal.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it throws a fireball out of the portal and incinerates everyone out that front of the portal.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so Jude walks out there and area effect...
[SPEAKER_01]: So they have to make a save.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I think it's save versus half damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, it is.
[SPEAKER_00]: But you have to roll damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: And here's the deal.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's...
[SPEAKER_00]: What is it?
[SPEAKER_00]: 6x8?
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to say it's something big.
[SPEAKER_00]: Plus, level stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: Harbaugh.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think it's 6x8.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, it's 8x6.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's see.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I was going to say, I'm pulling 6s.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do think it's 6.
[SPEAKER_00]: 8.6.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to use it as above?
[SPEAKER_00]: Third level or just do a third level?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'd like to do it above third level, but that would mean that, uh, let me double check on my... Do you have fourth level so far?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, I do have fourth level so far.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that only adds... Oh, I have one.
[SPEAKER_01]: One fourth level.
[SPEAKER_00]: That only adds one die six.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, so I won't then.
[SPEAKER_00]: I won't.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's eight die six.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's eight die six, so one, two, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: So eight die six...
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep, there you go.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ooh, that's nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's 18, 22, 25, 26, 30, 35, and then there are three people.
[SPEAKER_00]: And they have to make, even if they make their save, they take half damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's see about this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where are the 20s?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, over there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, I also have an extra 20 if you need it.
[SPEAKER_01]: 19-13-4.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you have no idea what happened.
[SPEAKER_00]: You troll a bull.
[SPEAKER_00]: The fire explodes.
[SPEAKER_00]: You hear screams.
[SPEAKER_00]: On the other side.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not a lot.
[SPEAKER_00]: But someone screams.
[SPEAKER_00]: And basically you hear people shouting outside.
[SPEAKER_00]: People.
[SPEAKER_00]: More than Roll 3?
[SPEAKER_00]: This is not inside.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's inside.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, it's inside Roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: So Roll inside.
[SPEAKER_00]: Was that Cox's?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, it's not.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't know what they're saying.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: But that's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll an edge.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was gonna say, I'm experienced enough to know they're like, surround the edges of the building!
[SPEAKER_01]: Fuck three.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I got a plus five, so I get eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twelve.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's your AC?
[SPEAKER_01]: My AC is...
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't have my AC marked.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't have my AC marked.
[SPEAKER_01]: So...
[SPEAKER_01]: It should be here.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know it should be here.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have nothing as far as they go?
[SPEAKER_00]: Your AC is your austerity plus 14.
[SPEAKER_00]: Your AC is 14.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, a bolt shoots through the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: So there's a magic user?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: A small dart shoots through the door.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it misses you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Another one comes through the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: 16 and hits the God you're dealing with.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can actually if you want.
[SPEAKER_00]: I remember when I was in my 20s and your dad told me.
[SPEAKER_00]: And this is the last story I've told.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sam, you don't eat chips.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's too salty.
[SPEAKER_00]: No sir.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, we'll put the chips up here.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll put them over.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can't have chips, mister.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, you already ate.
[SPEAKER_00]: You already did.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's just gonna go up here.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're gonna try to climb the mountain.
[SPEAKER_00]: Adrian, do you remember the steed are you taking right now, hon?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.